Frameworks were created because projects
required the same initial components, so
developers were doing
the same tasks over and
over, write out the initial HTML,
add standard default CSS,
and perhaps include some initial
basic JavaScript functionality.
There are many coding principles, but
two of my favorites are KISS, Keep It
Simple, and DRY, Don't Repeat Yourself.
Instead of doing the same steps over and
over, developers came up with
a base set of HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript, and created starter
projects from these files.
These starter projects are used as
a base or framework that can then be
extended with project-specific code
to create individualized websites.
A framework is built so
that it encourages you to write your
code following standard patterns and
to put your project's
files in specific places.
This helps to prevent spaghetti code,
to keep everything organized, and
to make it easier for
new devs to get up and running.